CNN anchor and correspondent Jake Tapper
aims to uncover the truth with his
hard-nosed interviews but now in his new
book tapri turns his attention from
learning the truth to writing fiction
his novel is called the Hellfire Club
it's a political thriller set in the
1950s Washington when the Red Scare and
McCarthyism ruled the city Keppler joins
us now at the table hey Jack Jake Tapper
it's so good you're here on breaking
news day two amazed and they've three my
favorite people it's gravy people right
now there's many favorite people true I
only met Ellen that moment yes I've
known you guys who are all lovely people
in real life as the viewers will be
happy to learn this Gracie
despite the way we're treating you now
really want to talk to you first about
dr. Ronnie Jackson because you come in
and do makeup and he's in you come out
of makeup and he's out that's the Trump
ear right you take a commercial break
and you look at your phone oh my god 15
more big stories of just bro what's your
reaction to it
it was unsustainable I mean the writing
was on the wall as soon as these stories
first started coming out you saw that
they were first put out there really by
Republicans on the hill Senate
Republicans who had been trying to
communicate with the White House hey
we've got concerns the White House
according to the Senate was unresponsive
and here are the concerns it is odd
though he calls the stories false and
fabricated and yet he withdraws I mean
if I had stories about me that were
false and fabricated I would stay and
fight we asked the operation of a full
White House to back you and prove that
there and put character witnesses up etc
you would put a whole fight behind this
is the problem with this White House
unfortunately for dr. Jackson is that
they didn't have the mechanism there
because they didn't do the vetting they
didn't have the process in place I mean
people can rail against the
establishment all they want and and
sometimes for good reason but sometimes
the establishment knows what it's doing
and in this case vetting and having
answers to questions ready is important
I always say when the word embattled is
before your name it's long before that
you beleaguered embattled and
disgruntled those are adjectives you
don't want anywhere near you and this is
a way in which the disruptive nature of
the internal process in the White House
hurts their own goal would you have to
get this guy in a job right I mean
we've all talked about this before
privately and publicly there's the
disruption of the Trump administration
that's good that's positive rethinking
the way we send troops to battle
rethinking our the way we go negotiate
trade agreements and then there's a
disruptive part that that hurts
everything he wants to achieve such as
basic competence not having in place the
the vetting and the information Jake and
you've written about veterans in some of
your previous books that you've written
three non-fiction books this is your
first fiction but my first novel yeah
first novel and it does have some
nonfiction elements in it historical
historical figures why did you want to
do this first of all just for fun I kept
reading and learning about historical
things that had taken place in
Washington that I thought were just
amazing and people didn't know about at
the time know about sins and I thought
it'd be fun to write also in a way
sometimes you can write with greater
clarity about your feelings about things
as opposed to the facts that you focus
on when you write nonfiction when you
write fiction there were things about
Washington that I've experienced and
wanted to write about including the
swampy nature of it the compromises
people come to town and are forced to
make and also when when writing about
Joe McCarthy just the indecency and lies
that he put forward that people didn't
take a stand about one of the great
things you do in this book is you show
the drip drip of the way people who come
with a set of values about personal
behavior but also about scientific
research and things just slowly start to
move that's how it works
right we've said we've all seen this
people who go to Washington they're good
people they want attention they want to
achieve good things like they like the
the main character in the book Charlie
martyr he comes to town he wants to
protect veterans he's a veteran of World
War two and then little by little he's
asked to make compromises and ultimately
next thing he knows he's in way over his
head and that's I see that happen all
the time in Washington people Democrats
Republicans they come to town they want
to do good and they're forced to make
compromises and they lose themselves
your book is also there's a list of
sources in the red one of them is I
thought something that of course is that
your that's my copy I thought oh well
only I had it but of course you do and
hardback oh you do well I don't have one
to one-up you and you've also written a
novel but anyway this is a great book
Washington confident
which is about this period yes why did
you pick the time period and you can
riff on this book if you want and what
it is
Washington confidential by Jacqueline
and Lee Mortimer is one of the sleaziest
grossest books and it's about Washington
DC and I think 1951 is when it came out
and it's just a muckraking book it was
getting you know got a bad review in The
Washington Post at the time from a young
cub reporter named Ben Bradley who
thought that it was a shamefully poorly
researched the time the era is is such a
fascinating one as I don't need to tell
you guys because you're all historical
history buffs but the 1950s it doesn't
get a lot of attention because it's
sandwich strike between World War Two
and the 60s but it's this time that we
idealize in American popular culture as
as sweet and serene and benign but truly
it's a time of menace like everything on
the surface might seem great if you're
if you're white but but because
certainly it was right before brown
before the Board of Education things
were not great for women etc but on the
on the surface it's like Pleasantville
but underneath there's McCarthyism
there's the Red Scare communists are
literally infiltrating our government it
is it is a horrific time and terrified
Jake you started writing this book about
three or four years ago did you possibly
could you possibly know there'd be so
many parallels with what's happening in
2018 is you're writing about 1954 I
think that's so interesting no yeah well
I mean I started it during the Obama
years and the swamp was resonant the
idea that the plate the Washington DC
and my novel and then and where we are
today
it's very swampy but know the stuff
about Joe McCarthy is a character in the
book and the stuff about how much he
smears and lies and just completely
takes over the political discourse and
and people in Washington have no idea
how to handle it they try to straddle
the worlds of is this okay can I let
this happen there are very few people in
in the media or Democrats or Republicans
who stand up against it
that's obviously resident today and no I
couldn't have predicted it you know they
say history doesn't repeat itself but it
rhymes I heard a lot of rhyming when
doing research on this but Jay talked
about people that you've been described
as a merciless Slayer of alternative
facts
there's some they said look at Jake
Tapper's face you can tell exactly what
he's thinking well you guys know me
that's just my face you know the
expressions from time to time on the on
the Straight Talk Express or our time on
Air Force One
and it's got you on Saturday Night Live
yeah yeah that's interesting when you're
writing a novel are you constantly
collecting from the daily work that you
do
character behavior the movements of
people's hands or was this something
that was not a part of your day to day
as you were writing it a little bit of
both I mean honestly writing the novel
was a relief from the day-to-day because
I didn't have to be I didn't have to
strictly a hue to fax as I do during the
day to day work as you guys do but also
you know you could see things going on
in in 2018 or 2017 16 when I was writing
the book and say oh that's interesting I
wonder how that would work in 1954 so
there are there are purposeful echoes of
today that I project backwards no
charlie martyr has an acute sense of
smell and everything so do you I do
that's like what are we smell like Jake
you guys careful hope and integrity yes
I like that thank you so great yeah it's
so great to say yes the Hellfire Club is
on sale now